halo 5 guardians is a game about
momentum it's fueled by new ideas and
propelled by some of the boldest changes
to this storied franchise yet some of
these ideas fail but others succeed and
although halo 5 falters at times it
whisks us through black holes in the
cross war-torn tropical islands at a
rapid pace we can only surrender to its
velocity and with Halo 5 developer 343
industries comes closer to meeting the
many expectations the halo name carries
with it in fact some facets of the
franchise's shooter formula are at their
best here
guardians introduces new player movement
open level design and an innovative new
multiplayer mode all to great effect it
also implements a new campaign structure
with eight playable characters across
two separate teams as one chases the
other across the universe on the one
hand you have blue team comprising the
cheat and three of his oldest Spartan
comrades on the other you have team
Osiris for soldiers new to the Spartan
program still learning each other's
idiosyncrasies the Spartans
relationships unfold across what amounts
to an extended chase sequence the Master
Chief is suspected of war crimes
so Locke and his team are ordered to
bring him in it's a bold thing turning
the face of your franchise into a
possible villain and it sets the stage
for what could be an intriguing
character study sadly though it never
delivers halo 5 pulled us through this
chase as it tries to tell a story about
responsibilities the nature of
artificial intelligence and the fall of
one's idols but while there might be a
compelling story to tell here 343
doesn't make use of the opportunities
before it cutscenes fade to black before
they feel finished character motivations
shift on a whim halo 5 guardians spans
several beautiful worlds with chromatic
mushroom fields at labyrinthian cave
networks but I seldom knew why I was
there there were also combat free
environments in Halo fives campaign in
which you explore small self-contained
areas before embarking on the next
mission
there are also audio logs that at their
best add backstory to Halo 5 world at
their worst though they don't fit their
added weight to an already disjointed
plot the exploration based areas and
diary entries only serve to slow down
the otherwise steady sprint through halo
5 worlds
but in the end my frustration with the
campaign's narrative was offset by how
good the gameplay feels three four three
has added several abilities to the usual
Spartan skill set granting new options
to the already tight controls you can
ground pound on suspecting enemies from
above you can dash to one side to avoid
that rocket barreling past your team now
more than ever I actually feel like a
super soldier that 343 has introduced
these drastic changes to the formula
while still maintaining that responsive
halo feel is admirable as a Halo veteran
this feels like I remember but also adds
another layer of nuance to my muscle
memory Halo 5 also features open-ended
mission layouts gone are the linear
pathways of the series past these new
environments function more as arenas
with varying elevations and avenues of
approach
there are also hidden weapon stashes and
vehicle depots and if you don't mind the
erratic narrative these missions are
worth replaying just to see them unfold
differently a second time in the end
halo 5 is best played cooperatively with
three other friends the ability to split
into two teams cover each other from
different angles and utilize every
weapon possible leads to a wide array of
emergent gameplay situations this style
of play also erases the weight of the
ally AI which fills any spots devoid of
the human player to be fair the AI
performs well at times after pointing
out a priority enemy target for example
my artificial teammates are quick to
focus their fire but other times the AI
is abysmal halo 5 grants you a second
chance before forcing a respawn allowing
your teammates to revive your dying
character but without a human touch this
situation devolves into a train of
suicide missions as the AI rushes in to
certain depth one by one but that's the
campaign now there's the multiplayer and
here halo 5 excels in fact this is the
best shape halos multiplayer has ever
taken the classic halo playlist such as
Slayer capture the flag and fan favorite
SWAT I'll ask you the modern multiplayer
progression system introduced with Halo
4 now instead of earning new weapon
options a lot Call of Duty
halo 5 returns to forum with Universal
weapon loadouts and by scattering power
weapons throughout each map delivers a
welcome departure from the tedious
unlocks
some of its predecessor while arena
feels great and captures the essence of
what makes Halo multiplayer compelling
it's the new warzone mode that the
parchments franchise tradition several
times over it takes inspiration from the
MOBA genre combining player versus
player tactics with player versus
environment combat and it's one of the
best new ideas and not just this series
but the shooter genre in general warzone
spans huge maps from lush jungles to
barren Arctic landscapes each team has a
plethora of options laid out before it
from capturing neutral zones to killing
enemy players to defeating AI combatants
matches are won by accruing points and
each kill each zone capture each slain
mini boss contributes to that total
teams must choose where to strike and
when to do so or zone is brilliant
because as with the rest of Halo 5 there
is momentum here but this is a force
that shifts from side to side with in
each match horizon-- isn't so much about
consistency
it's about adaptability and the team
that can roll with the punches and punch
back at the right moments will have the
upper hand after ranking up and
achieving certain accolades through Halo
5s multiplayer modes you'll earn
requisition points these act as currency
for 3 tiers of item packs each
containing random weapon unlocks vehicle
orders and aesthetic items and although
they're random they still succeed in
changing the way you play based on the
equipment available by gaining energy
throughout each match burned through
cards thereby granting weapons and
vehicles to aid in the battle
these can turn the tide of certain
skirmishes allowing you to defeat
certain bosses or take certain capture
zones when others can the requisition
system is a welcome departure from Halo
4's progressing system and I think it
might be the thing to keep me coming
back weeks after halo 5 releases in some
ways halo 5 is the boldest halo yet the
franchise's multiplayer is at its peak
with well-designed maps and balanced
player combat but then there's the
campaign which introduces fluid new
movement and open level design yet it
can't tell a dynamic story to match
there are signs of phenomenal shooter
here but certain narrative aspects feel
underdeveloped and they hold the
franchise's newest sequel back from True
Excellence like Spartan Locke and his
team 343 is chasing after something
bigger than itself and with halo 5
Guardians
close now if only it could reach out its
armed intake hole
you